carlos ha tomado una dosis inicial de un
medicamento por prescripción médica la
relación entre el tiempo transcurrido t
en horas desde que él tomó la primera
dosis y la cantidad de medicamento mdt
en miligramos en su sangre se modela con
la siguiente función en cuantas horas a
carlos le restarán un miligramo o un
miligramo de medicamento en la sangre
redondea la respuesta a la centésima más
cercana si es necesario bien queremos
que carlos tenga 1 miligramos de
medicamento en la sangre por lo tanto lo
que estamos buscando es para qué tiempo
la función gmt la función m de t que es
una función que depende del tiempo va a
ser igual a 1
gramos y es que observa la función m de
t está dada en miligramos así que vamos
a resolverlo y vamos a resolverlo usando
la definición de mdt m de t es igual a
quien a 20 que multiplica a m ha elevado
a la menos 0.8 t y esto lo vamos igualar
a 1 porque queremos obtener este tiempo
ahora para resolver el tiempo lo primero
que se me ocurren es dividir de ambos
lados entre 20 así que vamos a hacerlo
de este lado me va a quedar el elevado a
la menos 0.8 te va a ser igual a quien
bueno va a ser igual que 1 entre 20 que
1 entre 20 ahora bien uno sobre 20 esto
es exactamente lo mismo que 0.05 así que
lo voy a poner aquí cero
punto 05 y voy a dejar un espacio porque
ahora quiero preguntarte cómo resolvemos
esto y bueno es que una manera de
resolver esto es la siguiente me voy a
tomar de ambos lados de esta expresión
que tengo aquí el logaritmo natural
porque recuerda el logaritmo natural es
lo mismo que el logaritmo en base en así
que me lo voy a tomar del lado izquierdo
y también lo voy a tomar del lado
derecho y porque estoy haciendo todo
esto bueno porque recuerda lo siguiente
cuando tú tomas el logaritmo natural de
y elevado a la menos 0.8 temp esto es
exactamente lo mismo que decir a qué
potencia tengo que elevar m para que me
dé en elevado a la menos 0.08 tm es más
déjame escribirlo aquí el logaritmo
natural de bueno déjame ponerlo con su
respectivo color
y elevado a la menos 0.8 t
esto es exactamente lo mismo que decir
que me voy a tomar el logaritmo el
logaritmo en base en de quién bueno de
esta expresión que tengo aquí de y
elevado a la menos 0.8 t y observa lo
que dice aquí vamos a leerlo a que
potencia tengo que elevar en para que me
dé resultado en elevado a la menos 0.8 t
bueno esto es obvio esto es lo mismo que
menos 0.8 tm así que déjame escribirlo
esto de aquí se simplifican a menos 0.8
de esto del lado izquierdo ahora qué va
a pasar en el lado derecho bueno en el
lado derecho me voy a quedar
bueno pues simplemente con esto que
tengo aquí y al rato lo vamos a calcular
esto me va a quedar el logaritmo natural
de 0.05
de 0.05 muy bien ahora para obtener a ti
qué te parece si dividimos todo vamos a
dividir todo un entre menos 0.8 entre
menos 0.8 de tal manera que de este lado
este y este se va a ir me va a quedar
solamente ten y de este lado voy a
dividir todo también entre menos 0.8 muy
bien y ahora si me quedo solamente con
que te observa no estoy quedando con t
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho me
voy a quedar con todo esto que tengo
aquí así que va a ser buen momento para
que traiga la calculadora y veamos
cuánto es esto déjame traer por aquí
nuestra calculadora esta de aquí y vamos
a hacerlo me queda 0.05 ok
a esto le vamos a calcular su logaritmo
natural muy bien obtengo esto y esto
mismo lo voy a dividir entre 0.8
negativo y esto me va a dar de resultado
3 puntos 74 40
y recuerda que nos piden redondear la
respuesta a la centésima más cercana así
que me voy a quedar con tres puntos 74
déjame escribirlo el resultado de esto
es 3 puntos 74 horas es decir en 3
puntos 74 horas le quedarán un miligramo
de medicamento en la sangre
empezamos con 20 miligramos y después de
3 puntos 74 horas solamente le va a
quedar un miligramo y todo además
seguramente lo metaboliza en algo así
que ya está esta es la respuesta
correcta